sometimes people accuse me of not being
bipartisan enough on this show
they accuse me of focusing on the good
things republicans do and the bad things
democrats do so in the spirit of
bipartisanship i want to bring up a
terrific bill that a democrat state
representative filed last week in
oklahoma the legislator's name is
forrest bennett and his bill is hb
3129
which in his words quote codifies that a
father's financial responsibility to his
baby and their mom begins at conception
if oklahoma is going to restrict a
woman's right to choose we sure better
make sure the man involved can't just
walk away from his responsibility
now this is a great bill
it protects vulnerable single mothers it
stops deadbeat dads from abandoning
their kids and it acknowledges that life
begins at conception
which apparently was just too much for
this legislator and his democrat pals
because he just pulled his own bill
after finding out that pro-lifers liked
it
so much for that
i'm michael knowles and this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
my favorite comment on friday comes from
anonymous says
i feel sorry for the lady trying to
translate president potted plants
babbling into understandable sign
language i agree with you
i i do have a great deal of sympathy for
for poor jen saki she was getting
dragged over the weekend for something
that she had said we'll try to get to
that if we have time i do i feel that's
probably the hardest job
in the world
you really hope that if you're in that
kind of an impossible job where there's
no way you can succeed that you've got
you've got some financial stability
you've got something tangible stored up
such as birch gold right now inflation
is at 40-year highs and it's here to
stay because the government's dirty
little secret is
they want it
they do they want the inflation right
now inflation rates are higher than the
interest on treasury bonds so what does
that mean that means every day that
passes the government owes less on its
mountain of debt imagine if you had a
mortgage that had a negative interest
rate would you be in a hurry to pay it
off i don't think so so your pain is
their gain
protect your savings right now hedge
against inflation with gold from birch
gold
because the government is sabotaging the
value of the us dollar birch gold will
help you convert an eligible ira or 401k
into an ira backed by real gold
that is peace of mind that is why i love
birch gold with thousands of satisfied
customers and an a plus rating from the
better business bureau you can trust
birch gold to protect your savings text
knowles k w l e s to 9 8 9 8 9 8 to get
a free info kit on holding gold in a tax
sheltered account then call birch and
protect your hard earned savings text
knowles kennedywles to
989898 to get your free info kit now
this
saga of the oklahoma state
representative
was so funny
it illustrated not just the democrats
absolute incoherence on the issue of
life and abortion it also demonstrated
that the democrats have no idea what we
believe
this guy tweeted it out he tweeted out
what i just read to you
here's the bill
it's great if if women aren't going to
have the ability to get abortions then
men need to stick around and protect
those women
and all the pro-lifers who went
completely viral all the pro-lifers said
great awesome love it
let's do it
and then when this democrat found out
the pro-lifers liked it which he did not
expect
then he said oh okay never mind i'm
pulling the bill
yeah i was yeah i was gonna try to help
abandoned vulnerable pregnant single
mothers when i thought it was going to
irritate all the pro-lifers but now that
i know that you like it yeah never mind
screw you ladies deal with it yourself
you're on your own throwing you under
the bus just to own the cons that's
that's what this man
is doing
obviously conservatives love this bill
the the
pro-abortion people think that the
pro-lifers would hate this bill because
the pro-abortion people truly believe
that the only reason the pro-lifers are
pro-life is because pro-lifers hate
women
even the half of pro-lifers who are
women or more than half of pro-lifers
probably who are women
they hate women too they all that's the
only reason that anyone wants to take
away the license to abortion
and so this guy is absolutely shocked
the only conservative pushback i saw at
all and we're talking one or two little
posts around the internet was to say
that fathers ought to have even more
rights
not not to say the father should be able
to run away if they impregnate a woman
but to point out that family courts
are
are
pretty
tough on the fathers very often that
fathers in cases of divorce or in cases
of a woman getting pregnant the two not
getting married fathers don't have quite
as many rights as the women so the
answer to that of course is just make
divorce more difficult
the conservative answer to that is is
certainly still not
men should abandon women it's that it
should be much more difficult for men to
abandon women and women to abandon men
and to break up marriages which are
based on public vows
that's
the the real story here the real story
is one
of political misunderstanding
i
speak with some credibility on this by
the way too because i did support
abortion when i was first getting into
politics as a teenager i couldn't
understand the pro-life position
i was an atheist i was from a very
liberal place i don't think i knew a
single pro-lifer i don't think i knew a
single one
and so i just assumed oh that's it and i
believed everything i heard on cnn and i
believed everything i heard in the
mainstream media
and i just thought the pro-lifers hated
women
and then i
later on i
looked into it i did some reading i
spoke to a bioethicist i was i was
debating and when i thought about the
issue itself not just the psychobabble
political motivations of my opponents
i thought about the actual issue of
abortion well it was so clear
the baby's a baby the baby's human the
baby's alive and you shouldn't be able
to kill it okay it's so clear
and the pro-lifers
were some of the most pro-woman people
i've i've ever met and obviously
pro-family
the left does not understand
what we think
to some degree
there's misunderstanding going in the
other direction as well but i think
generally the right understands what the
left thinks there was a jonathan heights
study that he had done some years ago
social scientist on
how the left understands the right the
right understands the left he concluded
that the right understands the left much
better than the left understands the
right i see the argument for abortion
the argument for abortion is that
sometimes people
accidentally get pregnant and this
affects women differently than men and
so if women and men are supposed to be
exactly the same and completely
indiscernible then women need to be able
to kill the baby
that's the argument that was the
argument the 60s it's the argument today
it's just a ghastly
argument but i i i see the
motivations from a misunderstanding of
liberty that this comes from it's not
just because the pro-abortion people
hate babies or something like that it's
because they have a misunderstanding of
human nature and the relationship
between liberty and life and and all the
other sorts of rights and obligations
that we have
but they i don't think that they
understand
the pro-life side that well
you can tell you i was just down at the
the march for life in dc i spoke
speaking at these students for life
summit
on saturday and when you see the two
groups there you see the pro-lifers nice
normal they look normal they sound
normal they're praying they're happy
they've got nice signs and then you look
at the pro-abortion people and they're
shrieking like harpies and seders and
they've got all sorts of
crazy presentations about them and
they're screaming profanities well which
group do you think understands reality
better
which group seems more grounded who do
you want to be when you
grow up
these these
these words can be very confusing
pro-pro-life okay it's clear enough you
support the life pro-choice well okay
the choice
the choice to do what my friend
now speaking of life and death the cdc
on a completely different topic the cdc
is changing
the meaning of fully vaccinated rochelle
walensky
the head of the cdc has come out
and
and said that fully vaccinated is is a
term that's going to be retired
the new term that we're all going to use
is up to date what we really are working
to do is pivot the language to make sure
that everybody is is as up to date with
their cova 19 vaccines as they
personally could be should be based on
when they got their last vaccine so
importantly right now we're pivoting our
language we really want to make sure
people are up to date that means if you
recently got your second dose you're not
eligible for a booster you're up to date
if you are eligible for a booster and
you haven't gotten it you're not up to
date and you need to get your booster in
order to be up to date up to date up to
date up to date up to date she's really
drilling this new phrase home what
happened to fully vaccinated
what how come we're changing the
euphemisms here
you know that the left uses the
manipulation of language and euphemisms
to control our politics i wrote a book
on the subject it's called speechless
controlling words controlling minds
so thank you to everyone who has read it
already the left needs to change
euphemisms for two reasons
the first one is when the old euphemisms
become demonstrably false
or
the second one
is when the old euphemisms are no longer
working on people or very often it's
both
so here you see that the old euphemism
fully vaccinated
is no longer representative of the truth
because the first two vaccines are
insufficient and so you need to get a
third vaccine you need to get a booster
sometimes a fourth vaccine in israel
they did a study the fourth vaccine is
no longer
sufficient against the omicron variant
of covet so now they're talking about a
fifth vaccine so manifestly fully
vaccinated is no longer fully vaccinated
but if you keep just moving the goal
posts and changing the definition of
fully vaccinated then the word fully
doesn't mean anything so they've got to
change it to up to date fully vaccinated
is a definite period of time up to date
is a subscription model
up to date you can update all the time
you you see this with global warming
which began as global cooling right as
there was global cooling then
that was demonstrably false and it
didn't work on people
then you had global warming
and then particularly during the
hiatus the hiatus and warming which is
still debated among climate scientists
whether it happened how serious it was
but there it is thought that there was a
hiatus from 1998 to 2013 in which the
world didn't really warm up that much so
global warming became demonstrably false
and no longer working on people so then
they changed it to climate change
climate change never became demonstrably
false because it's an unfalsifiable
euphemism but it did stop working on
people so then it changed to climate
catastrophe or climate crisis sometimes
people just refer to it as climate
you're a climate denier as though i deny
the sunshine and the water in the clouds
you're a climate denier
they they have to change these
euphemisms constantly
and then people catch up and they'll
change them again and it goes on and on
and on and on and you are never
up to date
now
one euphemism that really
really irritates me is when you go to
the grocery store and you see on meat it
says product of usa when it's referring
to meat that obviously is not from the
usa which is why i trust good ranchers
85 of the grass-fed beef in the united
states is imported from overseas that
outrageous
these foreign products are often labeled
product of usa because they're minimally
processed here but they're not they're
not really from the usa do not buy cheap
imported beef that lacks true flavor go
to goodranchers.com knowles kennedwles
to cut through the misinformation and
get 100 american beef delivered to your
door today good ranchers only sells beef
that is born raised and harvested in the
usa they're 100 american and steakhouse
quality all of their steaks are usda
prime and choice graded which means the
steakhouse could come to you in a good
rancher's box of meat great rib eyes
great t-bones gourmet burgers
i really love all their cuts i really
really love the burgers and the fillets
are really great too plus save 30 bucks
with my code knowles can wles at
checkout that's 30 bucks off any box
biggest discount they've ever offered
today is the day to save big on your new
favorite steak they are the exclusive
meat company of the daily wire for good
reason go to goodranchers.com knowles
save 30 bucks make 2022 your most
flavorful year yet good ranchers
american meat delivered
speaking of words
the
new york city police commissioner
just spoke over the past few days
over a terrible attack on police
officers in harlem
two officers were shot one of them was
killed while responding to a domestic
call up in harlem which used to be a
terrible neighborhood
then it got much much better much much
safer and now it's getting terrible
again here's the police commissioner
tonight
a 22 year old
son
husband
officer
and friend
was killed
because he did what we asked him to do
countless officers lined the halls of
this hallway after carrying him in and
grieve for their brother
while praying
with everything they have for the other
i am struggling to find the words to
express the tragedy we are enduring
we're mourning
and we're angry we have four times this
month rushed to the scene of nypd
officers shot by violent criminals in
possession of deadly illegal guns i'll
ask mayor adams if he wants to say a few
words
the police commissioner has a lot of
passion in her voice
obviously this is a tragic event
but she doesn't have a lot of substance
in her speech you notice that
she says she's struggling to find the
words
i've got the words here are very simple
words
mayor adams
fire your weak prosecutors who are
refusing to prosecute criminals
and put those criminals in jail
those are pretty simple words
but she can't find them
i don't know why look maybe it's because
she's serving the mayor of new york the
weak mayor of new york
who refuses to deal with the crime issue
and so maybe she doesn't feel that she
has the political capital to talk about
this but if she's simply struggling to
find the words let me give you the words
mayor adams
fire your derelict prosecutors
who refuse to do their jobs and put
criminals in jail very very simple words
most defensive about this speech
did you hear that little bit she gets in
there she says this this
happened
she insinuated quite strongly this
happened
because of illegal guns
that's what's changed in new york is
that there are guns around
there
there have been guns around new york for
a very long time illegal guns too for a
very long time clearly the gun laws
aren't working that well
what has changed in the past few years
is not
that
there are new gun sales in new york
legal or illegal what has changed is not
that there's there are new guns being
manufactured that that are
dramatically different from the old guns
that were being manufactured
what has changed in new york is that
prosecutors won't do their job
because there is a new
leftist idea that the police are bad and
criminals are put upon and we need to be
tougher on the cops and weaker on the
criminals and we when when criminals
riot and loot and burn down buildings
during blm especially in new york we're
just going to let them off the hook
we're going to give them much lower
charges when we charge them at all and
for the majority of them the vast
majority of them we're just going to let
them off completely
and then you're surprised when crime
goes up
when the administration in new york
says the de blasio administration in
particular the one right before this new
mayor says
certain
crimes are no longer going to be
considered crimes and then when the
prosecutors come in and say even when
you do commit the crimes we're not going
to charge you for them and then you're
shocked when crime goes up
so fine i'm not
i'm not saying that this woman has it
entirely in her power
she's the police commissioner
but
spare me the sanctimony spare me the
emotion if you're not going to put any
substance behind it you're right there
the mayor's right there in the room use
there they're the words feel free to
borrow them from me i won't won't be
offended at all speaking of new york
the governor of new york doesn't seem to
be any better than the failed leadership
of the city of new york governor kathy
hokel who took over after
governor andrew cuomo was found to be a
little too handsy with his staff which
was really just the excuse to kick him
out because of his scandals over kovid
when he pretended to be the greatest
leader in the country on cove covet
turned out he was hiding numbers
hiding death numbers and sickness
numbers and the thousands of senior
citizens who were killed in new york and
nursing homes because of his stupid
policies he was hiding them including
from federal investigators
so democrats decided okay we're finally
going to kick this guy out and we're
going to use the sex scandal to do it so
kathy hokel takes over afterwards
and kathy hokel doubles down on the same
stupid policies not the exact same ones
but the same covid
incompetence that you saw from from
andrew cuomo so now two years in
governor kathy hokel is still insisting
on all sorts of crazy covet measures
even for kids in schools even measures
that have been
demonstrated to be not particularly
effective even for kids who are not at
particularly grave risk from covid and
you know what her excuses for this
her excuse is
kids are resilient
i know people are tired but i also say
one thing about the kids
my daughter had a meltdown over having
to put sneakers on to go to kindergarten
she got used to wearing sneakers in
school they just
they adapt better than adults do and
i'm really proud of the parents who made
sure that their kids understood this is
for their safety and got it done but
we're looking forward to the day we can
live the school as well as the uh the
business requirements we truly am
that'll be very fabulous day
your little children have to cover their
faces so they can never see anybody's
smiles and they can't really go see
their friends and they've got to be
completely isolated from their peers
even when they are in the same building
together they've got to be walled off
into pods and their education is going
to be severely compromised and their
social development is going to be really
really compromised but hey kathy hokel's
kid didn't want to wear sneakers one
time so it's basically the same kids are
resilient
you know kids kids are just resilient
i hate that phrase
that is one of the dumbest phrases in
our entire political discourse kids are
resilient
is the shrug
of adults harming kids
kids are resilient it's fine
are they kids are also easily
traumatized
no they're resilient
kids also have trouble articulating
the suffering that they're enduring
because of what you are doing to them
because they're kids so they they
haven't been educated yet they don't
their vocabulary is not as large their
introspection their analytical skills
are not as great so they just can't tell
you
the trauma that you're inflicting on
them when you lock them away from
society for two years use psychos but
don't worry kids are resilient
everybody suffers
everybody suffers in this world we're
not going to abolish suffering this is a
fact of life kids suffer too sometimes
it is inevitable i'm not saying that
every time a child suffers
it's necessarily someone's fault you can
necessarily fix it
you should necessarily fear feel
terrible about it
no people are going to suffer it's part
of growing up
but but do not pretend
that the suffering that you inflict that
you kathy hokel and other people who use
this phrase inflict is without
consequence that it's just totally fine
you probably hear this phrase most with
divorce uh kids are resilient it's fine
or if uh if a mother is moving a kid
around from place to place and putting
him in bad circumstances and oh that
well don't worry kids are resilient no
you're harming these kids you are
harming them and
i'm not saying that you need to go take
a long walk off a short pier because of
it people make mistakes bad things
happen but don't excuse it it's not
fix it fix it and don't just say well
don't worry they can bounce back no it's
in some ways kids are more resilient in
the sense that they're malleable but in
some ways they're much less resilient
than adults who have had time to mature
and have a have a
more balanced view of the world
and have have developed certain
callouses because of suffering they've
gone through don't worry it's fine hey
my kid couldn't tie her shoes one day so
let's lock them up for another three
years
what what a joke speaking of
how the radicals are messing with our
kids in schools another disturbing story
out of an elementary school in oregon
oregon gosh
that place a lot of stories coming out
of oregon
fourth graders at raleigh hills
elementary school
located in beaverton
oregon
were just presented with a slideshow a
couple of weeks ago daily wire just
learned this
unveiling the formation of a qsa club
that's queer what is it queer sexuality
alliance something to that effect
so there's a there's an lgbt club for
fourth graders in this school
and the lgbt club is recruiting the
students and it's being presented to the
students
and the parents have no idea there is no
parental consent required one of the
slides from this club it says
what will we do we'll have conversations
about identity gender equal rights and
social issues that are important to you
we'll explore lgbtq plus history and
activism we will discuss personal
struggles now we're getting real creepy
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
groom you kids is what it is what
they're
implying
we're gonna discuss personal struggles
and successes in a supportive space
we're gonna advocate for change
in our school and community but we're
going to advocate for change changing
what
we're going to talk about your personal
struggles in the sexuality club for
nine-year-olds
what personal struggles if you were
having
personal struggles in your sexual
relationships at nine
you should be recommended to a school
counselor
this this should be discouraged
nine-year-olds shouldn't be doing that
but instead it's being encouraged and
the parents have no right to say
anything about it
and frankly
by the logic of
our culture right now by really by the
logic of all cultures and societies
given the premises we're starting with
there's actually no reason for the
parents to be involved this is something
that conservatives don't quite
understand about there's really no
reason for the conservatives to be
involved if you accept all the radical
premises
to begin with
you know
people don't understand really really
simple things like why you don't need to
wait in line at an auto parts store when
you can just go to rockauto.com i've
sometimes pointed out on this show
that
if you go to the brick and mortar auto
parts store over rockauto.com you can
sometimes pay twice as much as you would
at rockauto but it occurs to me that's
not actually true
you you could actually end up paying
more than that more than twice as much
because your time is money
so you go you drive to the store you
wait in the line you talk to the guy you
get peppered with questions the guy goes
in the back they don't have the part
because there's a lot of parts it's a
difficult time right now for you know
that's good there's a lot of makes and
models but
the brick and mortar doesn't always have
the parts you gotta wait two weeks you
drive back you drive there your time is
money you can save both time and money
by going to rockoto.com family owned
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years super easy to
navigate the website no gimmicks on the
pricing just always the reliably low
prices go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck write knowles k wlas in there how
did you hear about sbox so they know
that we sent you also if you haven't
already go check out our new comedy
series truth yeller hosted by comedian
and podcaster adam carolla over at
dailywire.comwatch
in the next episode airing this thursday
adam gets controversial by mocking
hunter biden and the way our overlords
are attempting to crate train your kids
tj miller of silicon valley deadpool big
hero 6 and more
will join adam to drop some comedy gold
and prove that he knows how to identify
a grandma killer go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code miller for 25 off
you can get a brand new membership look
out for the new episode with tj miller
dropping this thursday we'll be right
back with a lot more
so these creepy pervert degenerate
administrators at an elementary school
in oregon are recruiting their
nine-year-old kids to join lgbtq club
and convince little johnny that he's
really little jane this is obviously
very creepy very wrong the people who
are pushing this should certainly be
fired if not prosecuted
and the the part that everyone's
focusing on
is that the parents weren't even
informed
the parents were that like that's the
worst part of this
i understand why people are focusing on
parental consent as the because
not only the left but also the right now
believes that consent
is the be-all and end-all of politics
and there's there's nothing deeper that
we can talk about it's all just about
procedure well we all just need to
consent and if you want to consent to
mutilate your body or do a ton of drugs
or or whatever that's totally fine but
you've got to make sure that you get
consent all they care about is
procedural norms you see this even in
some pro-life advocacy where they say
look i'm not telling new yorkers and
californians that they need to ban
abortion i'm just saying the supreme
court has no right to do it so we've got
to send it back to the states and then
if the people want to kill a zillion
babies a year in illinois that's totally
fine but it's not totally fine
the procedure matters it's true the
court shouldn't take rights away from
the states and from the people but the
substance matters too we also shouldn't
kill babies
yes the procedure matters parents should
have a say over their kids education
obviously parents should have some say
in how their kids are raised but the
substance matters too
namely
we shouldn't be teaching kids
gender theory when they're nine years
old pretending that all sorts of
eccentric sexual ideologies are totally
fine
probably the only the only sexual
ideology that you're not allowed to
teach in this elementary school is that
men are not women and men should should
marry should marry women and they should
live in a monogamous
household for life and have a family and
procreate that i bet you would be taken
to court if you taught that in this
school but you can teach everything else
why the reason for this it actually
makes perfect sense
is that
while we often think
that our substantive views
are downstream of procedural norms
very often it's the opposite
i'm using sort of technical language
here so what i mean by that is we think
that the things we actually believe
about what is good and true and
beautiful come downstream of how we come
to decide them is it the court is it the
we the people the is it the teachers is
it the pta is then we all come together
and we deliberate and then we form our
substantive views out of that but very
often it's the opposite
very often it's the things that we think
are good and true and beautiful
that decide how we decide other
questions
so our culture has decided
that
lgbtq plus there are now 5000 other
letters to it
is
good true
and completely beyond debate
not even just that you know two fellas
like each other on a navy ship out at
sea and you know that's one thing no
we're saying that even the t
okay we're we're talking about
boys can chop up their bodies and pump
themselves full of hormones and actually
become women that in our culture is
considered unassailable if you question
that in your job in your school
you can be kicked out you can be kicked
out of both of those places you can
certainly be punished
and depending on how you do it you might
even be charged with a crime
there was a bill in california
signed into law in 2017 that said that
if health care workers
misgender quote unquote their patience
they could be prosecuted misgender
meaning properly gender meaning there's
a man who thinks he's a woman and the
health care worker says hello sir that
health care worker could be prosecuted
according to the law now it's been
extremely controversial since it was
passed but
we have decided that that is the case so
of course if lgbtq is totally fine and
unassailable and beyond reproach and
beyond debate
then why why would you need the parent's
permission
why would you allow some bigoted hateful
false-minded parent
to
question something that we as a culture
have decided is unquestionable
we've we've concluded the substantive
issue
and so the procedure is going to change
whereas 10 years ago
you would have needed at least to get a
parent's permission slip for a club like
this probably you wouldn't even have a
club like this
today that's been decided
we live
in a society
the only way to have a society is for
certain things to be settled we need to
speak the same language we need to
believe
many of the many if not most of the same
things we need to
have have plenty of areas of the public
discourse where you you just take
everything for granted that's the only
that's how all societies work
and the left understands this which is
how they've completely transformed what
we believe and the right refuses to
understand this and they bury their head
in the sands
and they say well i'm not going to force
my opinions on you
you do you and i'll do me and why just
support individual freedom
and it's not really freedom at all it
just gives the left the whole playing
ground now there are ways to fight back
there's there's a great way i've got to
give chris ruffo credit because he was
one of the pioneers on this christopher
ruffo is at the manhattan institute
he's the guy who really popularized the
crusade against critical race theory
chris ruffo
had this brilliant idea
to
to make the issue of banning critical
race theory not merely one of banning
something from the curriculum though
that's what we're about
he wanted to make it about
curriculum transparency
such a brilliant phrase really a
brilliant tactic
because when you when you hear
from someone that they want to ban
something especially in a classroom
after decades and decades of the false
ideology of academic freedom we just
recoil from that even many conservatives
recoil this i don't want to ban anything
i just
you know i just don't want my kid to be
taught that white people are evil and
men are actually women but
but i don't want to ban anything come on
i'm not one of those censors i'm not
against academic freedom so
what chris ruffo suggested was
okay well let's make it about curriculum
transparency we all love transparency in
our modern liberal democratic age so
let's just hey teachers
let's just have you post your curricula
on the internet
so that the parents can see
what what happens
and then and then they'll make up their
own minds and we'll see what happens
from there because we know that these
teachers are teaching false hideous
dangerous
destructive things in the classroom
and the minute parents see it they're
going to freak out during kovid this was
one of the few silver linings in the
stormcloud of kovid
parents got to see what their kids are
being taught because the classroom came
through a laptop into the living room of
people's apartments and houses the
parents said what and you even had
administrators and teachers during the
remote teaching of kovid
say hey make sure that the parents
aren't in the room
when the kids are being taught this
stuff because they're going to lose
their minds as right as rightly they
they did
so nbc news now has this piece
anti-critical race theory activists have
a new focus
curriculum transparency
that's really bad
and this is this is really dangerous
because
transparency is a
liberal value but it's forcing
an ideological shift in the way that's
that's right that's exactly what it's
doing
the conservatives here have put
liberals
on the opposite side of transparency
they're now fighting against
transparency
this would be a good example
of something that i've suggested for a
while now which is not just that
politics is downstream of culture and
yet cult meaning culture affects
politics the movies what we listen to
the way we talk the media sure that
affects our government sure
but politics also affects
culture
the government also affects the civil
society
because
curriculum transparency is a law
it's a regulation
passed by the government
very rarely adopted voluntarily by the
school districts it's something where
the school board or the department of
education or the governor is going to
have to come in and say we need
curriculum transparency and the libs are
going to scream and howl about it
and then the parents are going to see
what's in the curricula and they're
going to push back against it
republicans just want a governorship in
very liberal virginia
on this issue
because
while there might be
ideological rigidity on
taxes entitlements immigration foreign
policy whatever
on education
on
how kids are being raised
there's much more there's much more of
an opportunity for conservatives to
bring over people who are not
traditionally on the right
really really smart move education
requires limits
free speech i love free speech free
speech requires limits there's no such
thing as perfectly absolute free speech
it's not possible we live in a society
all societies are going to have to speak
a common language they're going to have
to have some taboos they're going to
have to have some limits on what you can
say what you can't say
true free speech requires certain limits
religious freedom even religious freedom
in order to
truly have religious freedom you need
limits
on what religious freedom is great
example of it
i was just reading the radio can i
news outlet you know reading about can i
alaska as one does
and i noticed
that at a government assembly meeting
in the kanai peninsula borough assembly
there was just an invocation given
by a satanist
so each year this is according to radio
canai
a list of residents sign up to give an
invocation to the kanai peninsula
borough assembly meetings a list that
already is filled up for this coming
calendar year the policy states that the
assembly allows for an invocation which
could include a short prayer or
solemnizing message to be offered at the
beginning of the meetings for the
benefit of the assembly to accommodate
the spiritual needs of public officials
and for the past few years and just
happening again last tuesday
satanists are showing up
iris fontana signed up to give a satanic
temple invocation which several members
of the community objected to including
an assembly member who called upon
residents to silently stand strong in
prayer setting scripture from matthew 4
10. i'm not going to read the invocation
because i don't think satanists should
be
encouraged in our society
but
this is what's happening
it's religious freedom right
isn't that what religious freedom means
doesn't religious freedom mean
that the satanists should be allowed to
hail their dark lord and call upon the
devil to control this world
isn't that if
listen here listen here i might not
agree with what you say but i'll defend
of the death of your right to say it i
might not agree with hailing satan
prince of the underworld the father of
lies
the the embodiment of evil
but i will defend to your death no i
won't i won't i'm not going to defend
that right i don't think you have that
right i don't think the founding fathers
understood satanic invocations as being
covered by religious liberty
i think that if
someone had shown up to the continental
congress to give a satanic invocation
not only would this not be applauded by
those liberal-minded founding fathers uh
probably they would go out and and
gather kindling for the stake that they
would burn that person at
certainly in earlier america they would
do that
we know i think we all know
that
whatever religious liberty means in
america
it does not mean satanists opening up
our government meetings so i think we
need to start from if we want to get
back to any normal understanding of what
freedom means in america let's start
from there we know that
that satanists are not what our founding
fathers were talking about when they
talk about the blessings of liberty and
no establishment of religion
and and the various
other religious phrases that are used
within our founding documents okay so
then what does that mean for what
religious freedom actually is
in the united states tradition
in the united states tradition god is
referenced in our founding document the
declaration of independence the entire
country is predicated on the idea that
our creator
god has given us certain unalienable
rights
namely the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
not satan satan didn't give us those
rights
satan didn't create us as god
satan is the enemy of god he rebelled
against god and got shot down to hell
and
now he's being tormented for eternity
god is mentioned in many official united
states documents
god is on our money
in our money it says in god we trust
in our national
pledge of allegiance we say
one nation under god
our nation was founded even before the
founding of the american republic
our whole country which dates back much
further was founded by extremely zealous
christians
it's a christian country
that means that if you if you do not
accept certain at least basic premises
of christianity if you do not go along
with certain basic elements at least
then you don't really have a place here
i'm not saying you've got to be in daily
mass and receiving all the sacraments
i'm sure the founding fathers wouldn't
have said that either
but if you do not believe for instance
that
the good lord gives us certain rights
that we have a right to life that that
life is ordered toward pursuing liberty
and that that this is conducive toward
the pursuit of happiness if you don't
believe that then america doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense for you does
it
you certainly don't have a right to
undermine all of those things
liberty
cannot coherently be used to undermine
liberty
you don't have a first amendment right
for instance to destroy the first
amendment
right you don't that that doesn't make
any sense
for much of us history we've had
blasphemy laws
if you
if you blaspheme against god the
christian god you could be prosecuted
now we think that's unshocking
unbelievable so un-american no it's only
been considered un-american for the past
50 years or so
only since cultural revolutionaries
wield a hostile takeover of our
political processes of the government
and kicked the bible out of schools
kicked prayer out of schools and kicked
christianity out of the public square
and exalted satanism
that literally exalted satanism in
multiple places okay
so
if if we want to restore some semblance
of american religious liberty
i think we got to realize that somewhere
we went off the track and we need to
stop tolerating freaking baphomet at
government assemblies this is not
complicated folks good grief if you find
yourself on the same side as a horned
demon switch sides something's going
wrong it's not going to end well for you
speaking of satan
there is a group of
abortion activists who are pretending to
be catholic they call themselves the
catholics for choice you've got to
really put you got to put catholics in
quotes and choice in quotes because what
they really mean is leftists for
abortion but they're trying to
infiltrate and subvert the catholic
church
because the catholic church is
the most prominent pro-life institution
in the entire world
so over the weekend this was the march
for life weekend this group of abortion
activists projected images and texts
onto
a church the basilica
of the national shrine of the immaculate
conception in washington dc
it said pro-choice catholics you're not
alone lots of different messages
supporting abortion
now the cardinal
and the leader of the church in dc
is a very liberal
prelate
this guy when when donald trump visited
this shrine actually
this cardinal got angry he actually
objected to the president of the united
states visiting a catholic shrine in a
very respectful way
i really disagreed with that i thought
he was playing politics he's obviously a
liberal cardinal
but here here
his response to what these abortion
activists did was indus
indistinguishable from what a a very
conservative cardinal would have said he
wrote
this is cardinal wilton gregory
he said those whose antics projected
words on the outside of the church
building demonstrated by those pranks
that they really are external to the
church and they did so at night
john 13 30.
he just that's all he said john 13 30.
if you go look up in your bible or your
bible app what is john 13 30
it's the verse in which
christ identifies judas iscariot as his
betrayer
he's calling them judas
this is a really important lesson
for modernity for the whole modern world
from the catholic church even from a
relatively liberal catholic
bishop
the lesson is this
there are limits to self-definition
there are limits to self-expression
we don't understand that anymore
the left certainly does and they believe
that you can identify however you want
to identify but even a lot of
conservatives don't understand that
anymore
they think that look if i want to be
something
then
i can be that i'll pull myself up by my
bootstraps by golly and you're not going
to tell me that i can't do that and it's
it's a
conservatism because it's so heavily
tinged by libertarianism it's very
skeptical of any authority and it
doesn't want to be told what it is it
doesn't want to have these definitions
imposed on them
but there are limits to self-definition
what the cardinal is saying here is you
can call yourselves catholic but you're
not you're not because
you are clearly not in communion with
the church
and
you're not repentant and you're not
accessing the sacraments so you really
are external to the church and when you
talk about direct cooperation in an
abortion that incurs excommunication
automatically
excommunication meaning literally being
cut off it means you can't receive the
communion but it also means you're being
cut off from the church you're out and
it doesn't matter how you self-identify
and you might say well in my heart of
hearts i feel as though i'm a christian
well fine in my heart of hearts i might
feel like i'm a goldfish but i'm not
it's not up to you to decide that
there actual there actually is authority
that imposes definitions and you can't
just totally change the reality by
changing all of the words that's a very
important lesson to take away and it's
it's
the only way that conservatives are ever
going to be able to regain any kind of
ground in this battle i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show i'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show